welcome back to things you missed and
prepare yourself to relive your
childhood nightmares because in today's
episode we're looking at the teasers for
scary stories to tell in the dark stick
around to the end of this video if you
want to hear how these classic stories
tied together in this new movie at the
time of making this video there are four
teasers for scary stories to tell me
dark and they're filled with references
to the original trilogy of children's
horror stories now is more of a scary
stories for sleepovers kind of kid
myself maybe a little bit of goosebumps
but I'm definitely interested in the new
movie because the teasers look intense
like they're aimed for kids who grew up
with these stories and are now adults
let's take a look at the first clip
based on the iconic book series
[Music]
scary stories the creature in this
teaser is a recreation of the monster
from the short story called the dream
which appeared in scary stories 3 the
tale is about an artist named Lucy who
goes from town to town to paint various
villages she decides to go to a village
called Kingston but the night before
leaving she has a dream about this pale
skinned woman warning her to flee while
she still can that this is an evil place
so the next morning she wakes up and
decides to go to a different town
Dorset's as she's looking for a place to
stay in Dorset she looks at a room that
resembles the room from her dream which
makes her uneasy the landlady goes to
make some tea and give Lucy some time to
think it over when the pale skinned
woman appears before her sending Lucy
running for the hills in the movie the
creature approaches a boy down a long
hall with a red light which tells us
that this movie may not be an anthology
of scary stories adapted into short
films but rather that the stories exist
as stories within the world of the movie
and that maybe the characters find
themselves in trouble when they
discovered that these stories are true
another story from the book is showcased
in the next teaser scary story the story
is called the red spots and it's about a
girl named Ruth who's paid a visit by a
spider as she sleeps the next morning
she notices a red spot on her cheek that
looks like a spider bite but instead of
going away over time the spot grows
until one day at bursts while she's in
the bath and tons of baby spiders come
crawling out because the boil was
actually filled with spider eggs in the
movie the girl discovers a spider's leg
in the red spot before at verse and
she's in high school when happens the
roof tiles are similar to those in the
first teaser leading me to believe that
they could all be in the school together
if you know anything about the scary
stories books
you probably recognize the next monster
[Music]
this is the first story in the first
book in which a boy pulls out this toe
from the woods and he brings it home for
some reason and his mom prepares that as
part of her soup and they eat it for
dinner if you never want to have soup
again I completely understand
but not much is different here in the
movie because the next thing that
happens is the monster comes after the
boy the monster in the book is also
described as having a huge mouth and
teeth to chomp its victims bones but the
movie version looks more like the green
Giants last teaser is a little bit more
ambiguous it has the boy from the first
teaser who keeps saying we're next and
then this other kid is attacked by this
Green Goblin looking boo oh I don't
think there's a specific story or a
piece of artwork that this guy is from
in the books my guess is that this is
one of the many unseen monsters from the
stories probably 30% of all of these
stories in the books follow the exact
same formula where somebody's in a
spooky house or location and they hear
something coming towards them and
getting closer and closer and then
whatever it is that's making the sound
disappears and the story ends so my
guess is that this friendly looking guy
is one of those monsters but this time
he comes and breaks down the door
there's also this other shot in the
teaser this last one is just packed with
stuff and it appears to be water
dripping into a horse trough there are
three stories with horses in the series
one were which turns a man into a horse
at night one where two kids are attacked
by a ghostly tribe of men on horseback
and one where a fortune teller predicts
that a man's horse will lead to his
death which is most likely what we're
seeing here so how do all these stories
connect and make a movie according to
the studio a group of teenagers in the
60s discover a book of stories whose
legends begin to turn real resulting in
horrific deaths across their town so I
think they'll discover that the tales of
horror write about in the books are the
key to overcoming these monsters in real
life let me know in the comments if
there are any stories that you'd like to
see incorporated into the movie and
remember to subscribe to seize these
world and bring the death belt for
notification so you don't miss out on
upcoming things you missed episodes like
the scary stories official trailer and
if you love short horror stories click
on the playlist on the left to listen to
some creepy stories that I've written as
always I will see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]